I'd like to welcome
colleagues really from all across the
globe as well as the ones that are
actually here in person
and I guess a special thanks to Rima
fella shimra has actually really been
the main organizer for this event
and then of course Krista marchesa who
actually is here at the Yale child study
center and the director for
communication
as well as Angie Portugal who's With Us
online and she's actually going to be
monitoring all the questions that come
in during the various opportunities that
we have in terms of question and answer
period
so as many of you may know the Early
Childhood peace Consortium seeks to
engage members of the community here at
the Yale child study center as well as
the larger Yale community and Beyond to
explore the evidence that how we raise
our children can be a pathway to a more
peaceful world
and for the last two decades members of
The Early Childhood peace Consortium
that work together with other members of
the International Community many of whom
are actually with us this morning or
this afternoon depending on what area
code you live in uh and we are
continuing to make the effort to
establish a clinical movement to build a
more peaceful uh environment and another
member has just arrived so uh thank you
thank you for being downstairs I
appreciate it
so the goal of the Early Childhood peace
Consortium is to create a legacy of
sustained Peace by drawing on the
transformative power of Early Child
Development
and the global Community must address
the root causes of violence and
conflicts so that the children and
families can be agents of change for
peace and I guess I'd want to emphasize
the fact that we also need to very much
engage the children and the young people
because they are the Next Generation and
it's been a matter of a lot in terms of
their perspective as well
so our first presenter is uh dear Rima
Salah who I've known for
decades and she's the current chair of
the Early Childhood peace Consortium and
she is the has had all sorts of
important roles at the United Nations
and at UNICEF uh really working in a
number of countries throughout Africa
and other places but she's also been a
member of our volunteer faculty here at
the child study center and uh that's
wonderful that she's here is here for us
uh more than a decade so I think the
floor is yours
Primo yes thank you thank you Jim
distinguished participants dear
colleagues it gives me a great pleasure
to be with you this morning this
afternoon or this evening at the launch
of the new hybrid lecture series raising
children of Peace at the Yale chart
study center sponsored by The Early
Childhood peace Consortium I am
privileged to have the opportunity to
talk to you on a subject that concerns
us all in these very critical and trying
Times building a world of Peace the
promise of the Early Childhood peace
Consortium
today millions of children are trapped
in situations of War conflict
displacement and military occupation for
example according to save the children
report
2021 approximately
1.6 billion children were living in a
conflict-affected country
approximately
449 million children over one in six
were living less than five kilometers
from where the active fighting took
place some 230 million children lived in
high intensity conflict countries this
exposing them to killing maiming
violence abduction separation from their
families and denial of humanitarian
assistance
leading to an unprecedented crisis of
care and learning yes it is the story of
Lost childhood
what is allowing and should concern us
all is the lasting negative impact of
deprivation and violence both physical
and structural on young children and the
detrimental effect on children's
development
exposure to violence at an early age is
causally related to a broad range of
negative outcomes across the lifespan
including major emotional and behavioral
problems which can be self-perpetuating
and evidence-based science continues to
substantiate the link between the early
years of life and the early life
environment with long-term well-being it
also substantiates the link between
violent prevention and the development
of pro-social behavior that can lead to
more peaceful communities
based also on the medical journal the
Lancet into 2016 it is clear that the
formative years of life and Ultra and
inter-family and Community
relationships are powerful agents of
change then can promote resilience
social cohesion and peace
distinguished participants the good news
and hope is that the emerging science
Heralds a new era with Windows of
opportunities through the investment in
the positive early childhood development
of young children as a path creating a
culture of peace
sustaining peace at home in the
community and in a society as a part of
social transformation and violence
prevention
distinguished participants the United
Nations and the International Community
also Heralds also in New Era a new
vision for building peaceful societies
and here our people are at the center of
peace and development effort an era of
inclusion with all members of society
including families and children in the
service of peace the vision was captured
by the United Nations agenda for
sustainable development goals and you
know at the heart of the agenda is gold
16 which Advocates to promote peaceful
and inclusive societies for sustainable
development and provide access to
justice for all and build effective
accountable and inclusive institutions
at all level
the adoption of the agenda was a
particularly historical moment for
children especially the younger ones and
their parents the agenda for the first
time includes early childhood
development ecd and recognize that it's
essential not just for human development
but also for sustainable development
the Secretary General of the United
Nations his Excellency Antonio guterres
said violence against children is
widespread and pervasive but is not
inevitable by placing children at the
heart of the 2030 agenda and at the
center of all what we do we can realize
its Noble vision of a world free from
Fear a word free from violence for all
end of quotation
distinguished participants to raise the
voice of science to join the voice of we
the people in this new era for peace
that promote the participation of all
members of society in peace building
efforts as such calling for Innovative
and transformative approaches that
engage family parents and children in
the service of peace
and also to answer this call of action
the EPC was formed and launched at
UNICEF in September 2013 to join forces
with the International Community to
advance Global and National efforts to
prevent violence and build peace through
the transformative power of early
childhood development
astounding members include Yale
University
UNICEF the mother and child Foundation
asheb early years the organization for
young children and the United Nations
Alliance of civilization
it also brought together many
distinguished organizations and partners
from multiple sectors including Civil
Society social and mass media government
officials and bilateral agencies as well
as practitioners and Academia
the consortium's vision is to create an
inclusive movement for peace social
justice and prevention of violence
through using early childhood
development strategies and services not
only to mitigate the immediate and
long-term impact of violence and
deprivation on children but also to
build a strong foundation for peace
resilience social justice and social
cohesion
its goals include to link emerging
Knowledge from biobehavioral and
environmental Sciences with existing
evidence to increase investment advocate
for and create local and sustainable
programs for peace building and
reduction of violence through ecd and
also to contribute to the debate on
peace building by focusing on early
childhood development engaging
governments civil societies communities
families and children through science
and practice
to Advocate and disseminate information
for policy makers academics Educators
parents and Care given to build this
Global movement that values young
children and families as agents for
speech
also to promote and advocate for the
research and programs of the Consortium
members that are taking place in many
areas of the globe and that contribute
to building peace in societies and you
will hear from them afterwards and most
importantly raise the voices of families
parents and children who toil every day
in their cities in their villages in the
refugee camps to Anchor peace in their
homes and in their communities
we want you to join our movement
there is no better time than now for all
of us to unite our strengths to erect
the building blocks of a peaceful future
for all children let us all accompany
families let us accompany parents let us
accompany caregivers in raising children
of peace and the time is now thank you
thank you so much very much always a
pleasure to hear your presentation and
there's so much more that needs to be
done in this world of ours I did prepare
a couple of questions but I must say
you've answered both of them in terms of
how to fulfill the promise of Early
Childhood peace Consortium and how do we
make it into a more Global movement
and what is the role of universities and
academic institutions like the Yale
child study center and actually making
that happen
so I'm going to open the store for
questions we have a few people in the
audience here in person but Angie
portuga who is also a member of our
faculty is actually organizing things
with regard to the opportunities for
people to ask questions so uh is there
anybody that in the audience that has a
question that they would like to ask or
Angie can you also indicate if there are
questions that are coming into you
no questions in the chat yet Jim
okay
all right well I think it's time given
the time frame and the rest of us to uh
introduce Eduardo
uh and Eduardo has worked for decades uh
trying to address issues of the needs of
children and families affected by
conflict
and he's currently working for Unicef
and it's been a pleasure to get to know
him and he's uh although he's been in
many different parts of the world he's
currently the emergency specialist for
Early Child Development for Unicef so
Eduardo the floor is yours and hopefully
if you just push this button you can
advance the slides
okay terrific
thank you so much Jim and what a
privilege and what a pleasure to be here
uh to in this first of a series of of
lectures of the of the Early Childhood
peace Consortium I am actually the the
secretary of the Consortium
which is uh not only humbling is uh it's
a little bit scary because we we have a
lot of work to do and and it's such a
it fills you with energy to see the the
the the the the
names and the and the quality of people
in the in the Consortium and and and how
the enthusiasm and the energy uh it's uh
it's really
um moving us forward in this in this
agenda it is also a privilege and uh and
such a pleasure to be after after Rima
Salah who is a who is a good friend of
one of my heroes uh who has been such an
incredible advocate for linking some of
them very important agendas of the of
humanity early childhood development uh
peace building but also other areas that
are very important linked to the early
years of life such as gender equality uh
climate change and disabilities etc etc
so I want to I have a few minutes with
you uh for the moment I think I'm going
to come back uh and and engage much more
with the with the community that is so
interesting in peace building and and
and moving the agenda also of the Early
Childhood of early childhood development
and I wanted to have yes give you a
couple of of ideas uh that are a bit of
a base for future lectures but also for
food for thought right so I wanted to
concentrate in two things
the first of all is on science and and
Dr rimasala also mentioned science
several times in in her introductory
speech statement and so I want to to sum
up
uh hundreds of years of of research and
Science in three simple messages easy
right hundreds of years yes then in in
two minutes of in three messages and
then I'm going to to tell you how also
this is translated
for the humanitarian community so the
the ones the humanitarian workers like
me who are working in the field in many
countries uh responding to to to
conflict or to or to natural disaster
how we transform all these messages into
commitments for young children in the
field right and then I think we'll have
space in the weeks to come or in the
months to come to look at this very
specific examples of programs and and of
all the regions and and contexts of the
world
so
first of all science and very simply
what I aspire to do with this little
introduction is to change your lives
I am aspiring to change the way you are
looking at life the way you are looking
at yourself the way you are looking at
your nephews or your little nieces or
your children or your grandchildren or
your neighbors
so my three methods are default are the
following the first one is a
that
genetics and environment are very much
linked
and now it's something so so clear to us
our DNA is not our destiny we are going
to develop and to unlock and and and and
unfold the different skills and
capacities in relation to the
environment that is around us and there
is an element that is quite interesting
that now what we have discovered
oh we already guessed it before but now
we have a very clear uh um evidence for
that that we human beings as mammals we
are very social and we need love and
peace to develop healthy and to become
uh the best versions of ourselves if I
can if I can if I can say it that way in
a way I'm not going to talk about about
epigenetics we'll have time for other
for the for other
um uh for more you know engagement and
and and and discussions but that would
be the first message the second message
is that time matters and in my my slide
I put there I I did the reference to the
Bucharest study which is one of the most
for me it has been one of the most
interesting studies on early childhood
development uh what that what do I mean
by time matters
so what it happens in the brain of a
child is the following when we are in
the wombs of our mothers
and the neurons Stars developing
creating in the in the wombs of our
mothers and I think there are some
medicine students among the the
distinguished participants who who will
be much more articulated than I am to
explain that in in in in terms of
numbers
but when we are born with around
with around 100 million
100 billion neurons is that correct uh
Jim I look at Jim to go for confirmation
almost uh the connectivity of those
cells the synapses is is not that big
but it accelerates in a crazy way
through the engagement with the
environment to the age of three more or
less those first 1000 days of Life the
multiplication of these synaptic
synapses this electric connectivity in
the brain goes insane well it's not
insane it's actually something very same
but it's very very very strong
uh to the at the speed of around 1
million new neuronal connections per
second and from there to this in the
second
1000 first of Life there is a very close
pruning of the brain of the child right
pruning meaning there is a there is some
of those connections uh disappear
because the brain of a child becomes
very very specialized
what it means these very early period of
life is that we have a unique incredible
window of opportunity to set up who we
are and maybe you don't remember when
you those years of your life but that
was the the most formative essential
key moments of
your life that created who you are right
there's the opportunity in this
few years to set up empathetic human
beings who are going to be social who
are going to be more engaged who are
going to be healthier more
skilled so so all the potential that we
have when we are born we have that that
unique window of opportunity to to uh to
support this healthy happy development
and and create the peaceful the peaceful
human beings who are the elements of the
peaceful communities the peaceful
families and the peaceful communities
and the peaceful Nations that we all
Aspire for
I am not a determinist that doesn't mean
that we cannot do things afterwards of
course we are we we are working with the
adolescents and children some with
adults and with everyone we the the the
plasticity of the brain uh even if it is
um incredible in those years but it
exists until until we we we disappear my
third message is toxic stress what we
what the what our colleagues in this in
the area are now called toxic stress I
mentioned toxic stress uh obviously very
related to uh
to a difficult situations at home but
also in communities Rima has given us
very compelling compelling data on on
children living in situations uh of
conflict 1.6 billion uh children living
in countries where there is conflict
what it happens when there is toxic
stress what is happen when we have a
continuous response of the of the um
of the of the of the
systems in the body that responds to
those to that to that stress
what it happens is there is a risk there
is a risk of
derailment of healthy development and
that is not a small matter
uh because in situations of particularly
situations of emergency or in in
families where there is a lot of stress
uh that turns into
um toxic stress
we are risking the development of
children and the consolidation or the
creation the formation of peaceful
families who are the cells of peaceful
societies
so three simple messages and how do we
translate this into action and we are
going to see that much more we have to
really explore much more how we are
going to translate of the science and
all the knowledge that we have in this
incredible universities and these
amazing academics that have been
studying for for many many years also
obviously in in partnership with
practitioners Etc but how do we
translate of this knowledge into action
so we really build those more peaceful
societies who that can all these how can
the all these science help us to to work
effectively and efficiently in the field
in the most difficult
environments in the most difficult
communities and in countries where there
is conflict or where there is
emergencies and and a natural disasters
that create a lot of stress for families
and young children
so we have recently
make this much more official
to say when there is when there is an
emergency
we and the ones who are working in
emergencies with the support to with all
the nations and every every uh women and
man of Goodwill in the world we are
committing
to the children and we are committing to
the youngest children
so we have a a framework that help us
with this we call the cork the core
commitments for children in humanitarian
action and recently we have introduced
these uh three commitments for the
youngest children in emergencies and the
three commitments are very simple
and but they have an incredible and have
an incredible potential to transform
Societies in years to come
the three commitments refers first to
the services we provide to Children
quality services for the youngest
children in emergency are our priority
children have not only the serve but
they have also the right
to receive those services
when I started working in the
humanitarian world like 30 years ago I
have to say something I was not very
committed to the youngest children
because I was quite unaware of the
science that is behind that I that I was
explaining before and I was thinking as
a humanitarian worker I was thinking
well I have to concentrate in the ones
who are suffer the most are suffering
the most and see where we have the
biggest impact now I know that those are
actually the youngest children and
because the younger children don't say
you know the children who are one or two
they don't say oh my goodness me my my
early development is being derailing I
need help they don't need to say that
because we know it we have to provide
those services to them and services
include obviously uh Healthy nutrition
which is essential up to 75 of nutrients
in the body for for in the in the first
1000 years of life go to nourish only
one uh one uh one organ in the body the
brain because it has those incredible uh
incredible activity right of of that I
mentioned before all these new
connectivity so nutritious good food
which is not always easy in in countries
where they are suffering from from
conflict or whether it's uh uh
situations of natural disaster there are
many right now uh Health obviously
vaccination very very very basic things
uh hygiene clean hygiene we know what E
coli and the problems of bad hygiene
creating the development of a child
protection for the children obviously
and opportunities for learning also
right these opportunities for engaging
stimulation having also a responsive
caregiver caregiving is essential so all
these services and quality services are
fundamental for the younger children the
second obviously is to support the
parents and the caregivers to support
the mothers but also the fathers who
have to play a huge role in the
upbringing of children and and the
development of the brains of the
youngest ones and and caregivers and
this this one refers also to their
well-being and their mental health
particularly in in situations of
emergency we are extremely concerned
about the the the mental health the
stress and the and the stressors that
are around
families in situations of emergency and
finally the capacity of the Frontline
workers so it's not only the caregivers
but it's also our doctors our nurses our
nutritionists our social workers our
teachers those who have direct contact
with children who need to understand
what early early childhood development
is that they need to participate
positively in that in that development
and with that those three commitments
and three messages I thank you all and I
am
happy to give back the floor to Jim and
answer any question that uh
all at least to try to answer some of
the questions you are going to ask thank
you
[Applause]
so pleasure
pleasure to hear your presentations and
to be thoughtful about the work that
you're doing around the world
and I think you did mention something
about the number of children that are
affected by conflict and other realities
and uh it's really just heartbreaking
the number of children that are out
there and facing these challenges so
thank you very much for your
presentation and you also mentioned some
of the things that are currently ongoing
and UNICEF certainly has been leading
the way along with a number of other
International organizations to try and
address the needs of these children and
when you think about the realities and
Ukraine and other places where there's
child displacement there's separation of
family members it's really just tragic
and so much more needs to be done
so I think with that I will open it up
for questions from people in the
audience yes
so thank you for a wonderful
presentation
enjoyed the whole presentation and the
scientific approach for it one thing
that I was always wondering about I mean
um
the action in emergencies the approach
from UNICEF is that given the number of
kids young kids that they might suffer
throughout the I mean ages in different
parts of the globe so how UNICEF would
prioritize I mean different regions how
would I mean how does the policy allow
you to think about okay they have 10
emergencies around the globe so which
one should get the most I mean resources
because I suspect that the resources are
limited I mean we don't have endless
resources I appreciate it yeah thank you
very much I don't know if people online
only millions of people who are
following online I have heard the the
question but it's a it's a great
question how do we prioritize right and
how we are going to
in a world where there is so much
so many challenges how do we select one
country or the other or how to uh to
help this this community or the other
the reality is and and maybe uh talking
also about the scale of the problem that
maybe I should I should I should give a
couple of words on the scale of the
problem to address then your question on
how to select right how to I don't know
select is the world that how to
prioritize
um the reality is that every single
child and I don't want to be I am a
pretty optimistic person and and very uh
positive I have to say uh so don't get
this as a as a black cloud now for for
for depressing you but the reality is
that every single child in the world
today is affect affected at least by one
crisis
and one crisis affect every single child
in the world you know which one
Clyde May Cry client thank you Jim
climate change it really and we have had
them some some studies on that lately uh
we did a report and that every single
child of the world is affected by
climate climate climate change which can
affect the development in why when one
way or the other from lead to to heat
shocks to the development of every
single child in the world so that's
pretty hunting right if we think about
two of the mayor
um
indicators of of poor child development
which I will say is child poverty and
poor nutrition status just if we look
look up of child poverty we are looking
around more than 200 million children
that we have to uh that we have to um to
Target
uh in in emergencies and so and so for
and so on and so forth I mean there is
really hundreds of them I can tell you
for example an example in Pakistan when
the floats this last year the
unprecedented uh uh uh floating in
Pakistan affected 36 million people
I can tell you the reality is
there is no
there are no enough resources in the
world
to to address the magnitude of these
problems
in emergencies usually in my team we
said we do what we can right we look for
opportunities but it's not only
financial it's just one of them we look
at Financial Resources we look at Human
Resources we look at uh at the Community
Resources we look at at a natural
resource we look at any resources that
we can to to address depending you know
ad hoc and different cases but there is
also very good news in that sense
because we have incredible Partnerships
that are really helping with this we
have the children themselves and their
family themselves are the best and the
main Partners to address Child
Development obviously they are the ones
who do 90 of the development every of
young of youngest of the youngest
children and we have to work with them
as real Partners we have to go and and
in that case UNICEF has a little bit of
the U.N agencies we have an advantage
there because we we go hand in hand with
everyone including the governments and
authorities that also have a fundamental
role to play it's a puzzle of of of
Partnerships of of of hands that are
going to help the children with the
children and the families with the
families to address all those we and and
yes also one little important point
there
when there is emergencies when there is
conflict we do what we can Conflict by
definition
is the opposite of a conducive
environment from for development so
um buffer those environments to create
better better
um environments for development it's
that's what we do and we do as much as
we can thank you well thank you and I
think we're running a little bit short
of time but uh Angie I think there's
time at least for one question coming
from the virtual community is there
anything that comes to that you've seen
there is there is one question from
hinako
um and feel free to open up your mic and
share it
um
if there's enough time if not I've said
that we will pass it on to Eduardo and
then reply to it in written
communication as a briefing to the
presentations well why don't you go
ahead and have the person pose the
question and I'm sure that Ed horta will
be able to answer
for you or please feel free to open up
your mic yeah I'm happy to ask um hello
my name is
um hinako and I'm currently a graduate
student at the Harvard Graduate School
of Education and a mentee of Ambassador
and Laurel Chowdhury and
um so my question is a lot of my courses
conversation was about sort of the
protective factors of early childhood
development sort of adults thinking
about how to protect children but I'm
really curious because I think it's so
unique and Powerful to think about young
children themselves being the Agents of
peace and so I would sort of love to
hear how
um what skills should we be focusing on
fostering what are the developmentally
appropriate ways to recognize and
nurture the sense of agency for peace
among young children
um yeah
thank you very much I mean when you when
you mention young children you refer to
to adolescents if I am correct
or even younger
oh wow okay
yeah yeah that's that's a great question
I'm going to to to to to to to to
address or try to address a little bit
both uh the the youngest children are
um not only victims of Crisis they are
also uh the the the biggest asset to to
address crisis and through the
investments in early childhood
development we are looking at early
childhood development and the best ways
to to to construct a cohesive societies
not only for the future but in the
moment of the emergencies also
the the one of the good things I have to
say in in emergency is that the youngest
children the children under eight are
not controversial in many ways they
they're uh what everything can be
controversial but I would say it's one
of the least controversial things right
to feed and to to to to to support
children the younger children is going
to be one of the driving factors for
social cohesion and and and and and for
um
addressing addressing emergencies the
children the youngest children I think
we may be asking you to respond also and
you can send a message to Angie as for
the remainder because we're running a
little shorter yeah and we want Savannah
let's do that and then we we we take
this further because so we can talk
about the younger and the bit older The
Adolescents being engaged on supporting
early childhood development as the best
Advocates to do so thanks Jim thank you
okay
so I'm going to turn the floor over to
Siobhan but it's also fascinating
because one of the things that she's
been working on and I'm not sure if
Sherry Weston's in the audience or not
but when you think about Sesame Street
and the rest of it but she's going to be
actually sharing with us some of the
things that she's been doing in Northern
Ireland and in Ireland in general to
address this issue so I think I will
move ahead with this and uh
Siobhan is actually the current
chairperson of the international Network
on peace building for young children and
she's also the former Chief Executive
Officer of early years the organization
for young children and early years as a
non-profit organization that's been
working since 1965 to promote peace and
high quality child care for children and
their families based in Northern Ireland
so I'm not sure Siobhan if you're
actually able to advance the slides but
I can do that if you need I think I
think you're going to do it for me Jim
pardon me I think you're going to do it
for me I think that's what I was told
that you would Advance the slides many
thanks good afternoon good morning
everyone greetings from Northern Ireland
I'm sorry I can't be with you there in
the auditorium but perhaps sometime
during the lecture series
um in this session I hope to describe to
you how we as an organization
pioneered a culture of respect for
difference with young children and and
hopefully I'll be able to answer some of
the questions that have been raised so
far and our work was not only with young
children but also with their teachers
and parents against a backdrop of a
deeply divided Society scarred and
traumatized by 30 years of conflict
I will describe to you how we developed
a new program the midi initiative
respect indifference program and
implemented this across Northern Ireland
Ireland and Beyond and also subjected it
to a variety of evaluations including a
large random control trial
as Gemma said the organization was
founded in 1965 just a few short years
before the outbreak of conflict in 1969
and it was always committed to creating
a cross-community non-sectarian approach
ensuring that the two main Traditions
then Catholics and Protestants
Republican nationalist loyalist unionist
families could come together where
parents could get to know each other and
children could begin to play together
against the backdrop of what we
euphemistically call the troubles the
Northern Ireland conflict 1969 to 1994
these services for young children
provided a safe space for parents across
the religious divide and provided
opportunities to support one another
through the horror that was unfolding
around them
after the ceasefires in 1994 and with
investment by the European Union and the
special support program for peace and
Reconciliation
investment in Early Childhood Services
was seen and still is seen as one of the
key vehicles for building the peace in
Northern Ireland
the signing of the Good Friday agreement
in 1998 was a significant step forward
in terms of taking the gun out of Irish
politics
The Good Friday agreement with a focus
on rights social justice and
Reconciliation presented a very positive
policy environment for the development
of services for young children
given our long history of supporting
high quality
non-sectarian evidence-informed early
Year services we were confident that
Early Childhood Services could play and
ever increasing role in The Quest for
social cohesion and peace building thank
you Jim for sharing
um this next slide because the
publication of This research in 2001.
too young to notice question mark was a
wake-up call for us all in the early
childhood sector
the research presented the harsh reality
the children as young as three in
Northern Ireland while developing
positive aspects of their own identity
were however developing negative
prejudicial attitudes to others and as
you can see by the age of six these
attitudes were becoming embedded
the research also challenged a
prevailing View at the time
that young children were too young to
notice the sectarian divisions that
surrounded them
This research was a catalyst for us in
the organization to rethink our approach
to dealing with issues of race religion
ethnicity and identity
and we took an explicit intentional
approach to move from being a
non-sectarian organization to becoming
an anti-sectarian organization
we were supported with a range of
multi-level stakeholder Partnerships
including media Academia education
Partners policy makers to work
collaboratively to develop a new early
years program that became known as the
media initiative next slide please Jim
the program aimed to develop a respect
indifference culture that celebrated the
variety of differences in Northern
Ireland society and while ethnic and
religious differences had been the heart
at the heart of our conflict there was a
recognition of the need to celebrate
other emerging differences on the basis
of race disability gender and also
promote an anti-bullying respectful
culture that would underpin
relationships between children parents
teachers and The Wider community
the program had a number of distinct new
components the development of five
Persona characters representing
religious physical ethnic and race
differences the development of five
cartoon television messages
reflected instances of exclusion and
inclusion these messages were initially
played on National Television regularly
throughout the year and were watched by
children parents and The Wider community
the development of a new curriculum and
service design manual aimed at
supporting Preschool teachers implement
this new approach in a culturally and
contextually appropriate manner new
training for preschool teachers and
parents based on reflective techniques
that helped parents and teachers reflect
on their own experience of difference
and supporting them to understand and
respect the other
the development of new resources
reflecting the religious cultural
sporting and musical Traditions within a
divided Society
capacity building from management
committees School leaders so that they
could support the development of
anti-sectarian policies and strategies
within their local services and their
local communities
this new program was influenced by the
need to move away from a superficial
approach to dealing with religious race
and ethnic issues traditionally in
Northern Ireland Early Childhood
programs had adopted a neutral approach
to such issues which in fact meant they
were often ignored
we wanted to move away from approaches
that supported limited contact for
children from different religious ethic
ethnic and social economic backgrounds
and were Keen to create deep meaningful
prolonged daily experiences for children
families and teachers we were influenced
by theorists on social cohesion that
stressed the importance of building
trust respect for each other and a sense
of belonging the program was initially
targeted at three and four-year-olds but
has since been extended to work with
two-year-olds and eight-year-olds in
full day care settings and in after
school environments
we were introducing a new approach an
approach that took an intentional
anti-sectarian contextually appropriate
Focus to the issues that had caused
enormous division within Northern
Ireland Society
sport music cultural activities and
flags were often symbols of division
across Northern Ireland society and yet
this new approach intentionally used
these symbols of division to create a
culture of respect and understanding
difference
it was vitally important therefore that
evidence ensured that the approach was
not further exacerbating at the
situation and creating even further
divisions next slide please Jim
between 2003 and 2010 early years
continued to develop and implement the
program and with support from Atlantic
philanthropies we were able to
commission Queen's University in Belfast
stradmillus college and the National
Children's Bureau to carry out a random
control trial involving 80 preschool
settings in both Northern Ireland and
the Republic of Ireland and this was
coupled with a number of qualitative
case studies
the results were a positive indication
that the midi initiative was having a
significant impact in supporting young
children's social and emotional
development and creating a culture of
inclusion and respect in reference
the positive results from the random
control trial and the quality of case
studies brought both political and
thunder attention to the Innovative
approach and over the next decade
investment for implementation and going
to scale was provided by a number of
sources
since
2010 until now early years has developed
a systematic approach to both scaling up
and implementation
the approach has involved developing a
scaling up strategy
establishing implementation teams a
detailed advocacy and sensitive
sensitization strategy to convince case
stakeholders to a sport to support
implementation and provide political
financial and institutional
sustainability
since its Inception the program has been
adapted and implemented in a range of
local and Global contexts the program
has been successfully implemented and
evaluated in the western Balkans in
Kyrgyzstan and Tajikistan and it is
hoped that we will implement the program
in Palestine Israel and Colombia
the midi initiative has also been a
significant component in the new shared
education program in Northern Ireland
and the Republic of Ireland through the
sharing from the start project funded by
the European Union
and this program aims to provide young
children with even greater educational
opportunities to be educated together
rather in the segregated system that has
been the system to date
in subsequent lectures I hope to share
with you the details of the on the
international Network on peace building
and perspectives from Key Global
Partners who have adapted and
implemented the model that has been
developed in Northern Ireland thank you
thank you so much I'm not sure we have
time for many questions that it does
bring to mind the work of Sesame
Workshop and all the work that they've
been doing I think they have their
programs impressed pres present at least
in 150 countries around the world
and by interacting and directly having
an impact on young children and their
parents are making a real difference
around the globe but any questions from
the audience
and uh Angie anybody have a question
that they've posed to you not in the
chat
okay
well I think in that case we may move on
but uh thank you again Siobhan for your
presentation and uh
we are optimistic in terms of what the
realities are in Northern Ireland and
you've been having an important impact
uh for decades so thank you thank you
thank you
so here just as a picture of Angie
portuga who is leading the chat uh Kyle
Pruitt who I will be ending of this
morning's uh this afternoon session and
also a picture of Catherine Patrick Rick
who is one of the individuals that's
been helping lead the way but there's
actually us here in Yale and is actually
the head of one of the residential
colleges Morris College here at Yale
and uh talks to the families that we
serve to say nothing of our own children
and grandchildren and as a father and
grandfather this is a real issue for me
and I want to hear from the audience but
your thoughts are about how it has to
encourage Inspire and motivate the Next
Generation to join us to build a more
peaceful world
we need to work together to make that
happen and I guess I would be interested
in your thoughts about help us to
perceive that reality
it also makes me think of a few quotes
from Mahatma Gandhi and Nelson Mandela
as well as this book that we put
together it was published back in 2014.
Pathways to peace the transformative
power of Children and Families where we
brought together 70 different uh experts
with regard to a whole range of issues
from basic science to policy to talk
about the realities and how West to
address this issue with regard to
building a pathway to peace but uh I'll
just read the two quotes from uh Gandhi
and Medela if we were to teach real
peace in this world and appear to carry
on a real war against War we must begin
with the children
and you must help them be the change
that you wish to see in the world
and there can be no inner revelation of
the society soul and the way it treats
its children
so positive well-being and healthy
development young children Starting In
Utero has been linked to productive safe
responsive supportive and stimulating
environments so that's a thought to
Eduardo's presentation as well
that we need to do all we can to Foster
positive parents for all the parents
that we serve to say nothing of our
families and it's one family at a time
one child at a time and we need to make
a real difference
children have to be love protected and
well nourished to promote peace and
children even young children need to
have a voice an agency to promote peace
so with that I will leave the floor open
for questions and thank you all for
joining us today and any questions from
the audience
well in that case I'll turn the floor
over to Angie and any answers to the
questions that I posed
not to the ones you have not to your
remarks um there is a question that I
will send directly to Chobani in the
interest of time well why don't you go
ahead because we're running a little
over time but I think given the fact
that we're actually recording this and
the rest of it I would really like to
hear from the participant what question
they had sure Blythe if if you would
like to open your microphone up please
do so if not I'm happy to transfer your
question
um I'm a past chair of the peace
education Sig of the American
educational research Association and at
the time that I was chair we did work
with doctors Ian and Ian from Ireland
and my question was how is the work that
you have just reported related to their
work over the years
so I think that's a question for you
Siobhan yeah thank you thank you uh
Blythe I am also aware of their work uh
but this this work um that I've spoken
about was a combination of work um from
Queen's University Dr Paul Conley and
and Dr Alan Smith in the in the
University of Ulster but but naturally
uh there is a an overlap with the work
uh that the ants have been doing here as
well
so I think I'd like to end uh this uh
today's uh presentations with uh a quote
from Kyle Pruitt who unfortunately is
not able to join us but he is a graduate
of Yale College
it's also a whiffenpoof which is one of
the singing organizations that is well
known across the globe in terms of their
talent
and he's actually
um composed and has been working with
children and we're not able to hear the
the song itself today but I will quote
the uh and it's called seeds of peace I
will just quote the first uh
uh stanza
Welcome to our world my child
come to our world with each new life we
have a chance to plant the seeds of
peace
holding your tiny hands nestled in our
own we hold you close throughout the
night till the morning sun returns
feeling safe at home so is the seeds of
peace
feeling safe at home so it succeeds of
so with that I think I will thank you
everyone for hearing us if it's a big
face and uh looking forward to hearing
the final version of that that will be
recorded and believe it or not from a
series of children as well as with Kyle
so thank you all very much and it's been
a pleasure and honor to be here and I'm
grateful for all of the support that
we've received and I'm very grateful so
thank you
[Music]